while many across the country continue
to grieve over the June twelfth attack
at the Orlando pulse nightclub the
American media has brought out some of
those old familiar scripts Isis Isis
Isis Isis Isis Isis so how did many
media outlets choose to frame the
Orlando attack as soon as news broke out
that the shooter was Omar mateen an
Afghan American media outlets rushed to
bring on terrorism and national security
pundits the story immediately without
much initial information became about
so-called homegrown terrorism then it
was revealed that mateen claimed to be
with Isis during a 911 phone call
sources tell NBC News's Pete Williams
that before opening fire mateen called
911 pledged allegiance to Isis leader
Abu Bakr Bakr al-baghdadi on cube both
presumptive presidential nominees as
well as other politicians suggested
escalating US airstrikes against Isis we
have to really increase the bombing we
should keep the pressure on ramping up
the air campaign and Trump while
claiming solidarity with the LGBTQ
community double down on his
anti-immigration anti-refugee and
anti-muslim positions we have no idea
where they come from we have no idea who
the hell they are but here's a snag
despite mateen saying he was with Isis
they're still actually no proven link we
have not been able to uncover any direct
link between that individual mateen and
a foreign terrorist organization the
president and the FBI have said that
matina was quote inspired by various
extremist information found online but
they've yet to present evidence to back
that up and it still means that there
was no actual relationship between
mateen and isis or any group for that
matter that hasn't stopped the focus on
Isis and so called radical Islam and
that's important because it takes away
from two defining characteristics of
your lando attack and easily accessible
semi-automatic weapon and that LGBTQ
people were specifically targeted in a
space allegedly frequented by the
shooter so instead of focusing on gun
control measures and fighting anti LGBTQ
bills the focus became more on the
threat of Isis and by continuing to
linked to Isis fear-mongering about
Muslims is just further inflamed
Trump reacting to the horrific attacks
in orlando by doubling down on his
proposed temporary ban on Muslims
entering the u.s. now there has been
some good moments in the media coverage
CNN's Anderson Cooper called out
Florida's Attorney General Pam Bondi
after said anyone who would attack
Florida's LGBTQ community would be
prosecuted to the full extent of the law
you basically gone after gay people said
that in court that gay people simply by
fighting for marriage equality we're
trying to do harm there's also been
considerable commemoration of the dead
and the lifting of the voices of the
survivors and a nearly 15 our democratic
filibuster did end in the GOP agreeing
to vote on two gun control measures but
with the unproven Isis link still making
headlines is the damage already done